hey this is just the best this is
brilliantly subtle trolling by someone
that actually we know during Donald
Trump's speech at CPAC on Friday a lot
of attendees were spotted on camera
waving flags that said Trump on them and
if you look at the flags and for our TV
audience we'll show you a few of the
pictures of people holding these flags
at CPAC these were presumably Trump
supporters and conservatives waving
these Trump Flags turns out that these
were Russian flags a pair of anti-trump
activists named Ryan Clayton who I know
personally and actually spoke to not
that long ago and also Jason Charter
actually handed out these flags at CPAC
and told people to take them out and
wave them during the Trump speech and
CPAC staff quickly ran around to
confiscate them from everyone you
actually also have pictures that were
showing you of staffers coming around
and grabbing these flags yes these flags
were red white and blue but they were
the Russian red white and blue flags not
the American red white and blue flags
obviously these Trump supporters were
some combination of naive and clueless
that these were Russian flags many
trumpets wouldn't know a Russian flag if
it hit him in the face and at the moment
that the flags were being confiscated
Donald Trump was actually in the middle
of his speech talking about how the
entire Flinn Russia thing was because of
fake news I don't know if we can call
that symbolic or poetic or ironic or
whatever here's a little video of Ryan
Clayton being interviewed at CPAC he was
interviewed by some right-wing group
about Milo yu-na police being his
invitation being rescinded by CPAC and
this is just the best hee-ho he's
holding the flag and goes into a fake
Russian accent and it's just so so funny
hilariously subtle trolling hi this is
Jennifer Lawrence with the America first
project we're standing here with Ryan
who has very interesting Trump flags so
understand CPAC is a private institution
they can ban whoever they want do you
personally support their decision to ban
Mylo from speaking the through via I so
excited to be in America for the Trump
bration he a great man like President
Putin Putin he'll pick him for Americans
because they need leader like Putin in
America too and that is like top is
great Trump Trump USA USSR I mean Russia
I mean I know some people think that
this entire thing is very silly but to
infiltrate in this way to be interviewed
and then to pretend to be some Russian
guy who loves Trump to hand out Russian
flags which Trump supporters are too
clueless to realize are Russian flags
this is amazing and if you keep watching
this video the reporter there Jennifer
Lawrence not the actress keeps trying to
press him and expose him as a fake by
asking why are you speaking English with
the Russian accent all these strange
questions you're not gonna be able to
pin him down you're not gonna be able to
win this exchange you should probably
just walk away at that boy yeah and it
did not go particularly well for her if
you check out the rest of the interview
I am kind of surprised that he wasn't
stopped or kicked out while handing out
the flags that he wasn't keeping a
particularly low profile as this
interview suggests so I I don't know
what exactly the security situation was
at CPAC the organization but ultimately
at the point at which Trump got to
talking about Russia during the speech
these staffers figured out hey maybe we
don't want the Russian flags out there
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s